yo how do you kind of look back at the
Grand Hustle era of your career because
when you were on Grand Hustle it was
like the hottest [__] moving yeah like I
think a lot of things probably you know
kind of went wrong or you know I mean
obviously Bob is a star I think Trader
truth is on Grand Hustle my am I
tripping tip had a hell of a roster if
we really want to put it into
perspective young bro I actually really
like the guy that snitched Alpha Mega
yeah you like dopamega he was hard as
[__] but but you know he was kind of
like the first six nine
he was an early teller because he was a
fire he was on that road bro he was on
that record with Busta Rhymes yeah we
had to perform that without tip at the
hip-hop Awards when tip God was it was
that called hurt yeah it hurt oh yeah
his voice was crazy yeah we performed
that I just somebody just recently sent
me that YouTube video it was like why
clef opened up and then we and then me
[__] Alpha Mega and Buster performed
hurt without tip because he was
incarcerated people were he had just got
locked up like literally that day do you
think him getting locked up like kind of
affected like the trajectory of the
label as a whole in a sense I mean you
know because he had Meek Mill was
originally ground hustle and I didn't
know that yeah Meek was over a groundhog
I think I did nothing for a period of
time you know I mean you know Travis
Scott was I remember Travis Travis was
Grand Hustle yup um B.o.B Iggy Azalea
um oh man you know tip tip has had a his
hand in a in in a nice you know uh
I don't think he gets the credit that he
should deserve when it comes to like
having a knife for talent I agree TI is
an amazing eye for talent yeah yeah and
then you know there's others that he
like he talks about you know Savage and
Thug coming to him wanting to sign and
you know him telling him look like I
think you should do it this way I could
give you this million dollars but you
know just I could give you this game
that'll go a lot farther so
um yeah but but as far as like that time
in my career I don't know if what I want
to call it like a golden era but it was
a hell of a it was a hell of a time like
you know being TI's DJ when TI was like
the hottest number one rapper like he
was literally the hottest rapper out
like you know we was we was doing
tours across the state I went around we
went around the world together
um he was doing [__] Chevy
commercials he was like I was in ATL
like you know he he had the number one
album and number one movie out at the
same time like you know it was on fire I
mean literally I got to go on tour with
Jay-Z because of tip um and then you
know my brand gangster girls was the
hottest thing going so like you know to
be DJ Drama and and what ti was and for
us to you know be together at that time
it was like it was kind of what I had
always
I dreamed for in a way of like a DJ
artist relationship like growing up
looking at you know Run DMC and Jam
Master Jay and fresh prince and Jazzy
Jeff or being Rakim or even like cool
kid at 50 or like yeah you guys were
like synonymous with each other for a
minute yeah like green and M early on
like when when I when I when tip was
like rising and like I was doing my
thing and I was like oh yeah like this
is this could be my guy you know what
I'm saying so you know I like I used to
literally go to the studio to the
groundhog Studios which later became my
Studios but I would literally go there
like every day just to be around just to
kind of like Vibe for that DJ Gig
because I knew what that's coming what
that could be yeah
and then we had some hell of a times on
the road like I saw a lot of a lot of a
lot of things what was the Jay-Z tour so
originally it was the best of both
worlds tour and the one that like went
left the incident happened in New York
and during the New York show
Jay was bringing out a bunch of people
one and then that was when tip had bring
him out out so he brought tip out for
that show so after that show it became
basically the jay-zm Friends tour so we
wound up on the tour so for the next
like month you know I was on the road
watching [__]
Jay-Z DMX Mary J Blige perform every
night you know like it was crazy it was
insane like you know this is like 0-4 it
was all it was insane oh four who was it
who was Jay's DJ at that time was it
Neil Armstrong
um Jay didn't have
a DJ if I'm not mistaken they were
running the board just running the the
the the
um the instant replay from the from the
side
yeah speaking of shout out to Green
Lantern and a legend Greenland Jay-Z's
DJ Eminem's DJ Nazis DJ like who can say
that I tell them that all the time one
of my personal favorite mixtape creators
of all time oh yeah he's like those
Green Lantern remixes oh there's no
gangster girls if there's no Green
Lantern Green Lantern is a fight like we
used to like salivate pause over Green's
tapes like we was when green would drop
we would sit there and just like the rap
phenomenon [__] we would be so
overwhelmed and just so like yo we gotta
get on our [__] like you know Green was
green was our green was our Idol bro
like even before I knew him like you
know and and now like he's such a great
personal friend of mine but like coming
up like Green Lantern was the epitome of
what I wanted to be as a mixtape DJ
shout out to Green